the tree trimmers were able to get the
man out of the truck where he ran away
still wearing nothing but his bathing
suit so well he didn't gain clothes yeah
you're not going to go into a tree
trimmer truck and suddenly like have
like an outfit change
we want to thank our sponsor prize picks
guys price picks is the most fun we've
had winning up to 25 times our money
this football season all you have to do
is select two or more players pick more
or less their projected stats and place
your entry go to prize picks.com DPT and
use the code DPT for a first deposit
match of up to 100 that's prizepix.com
DPT use the code DPT for a first deposit
match up to 100 prize picks daily
fantasy sports Made Easy hey townies
welcome to another episode of dumb
people Town population news population
Lapkus
labcas welcome to the show how are you
hi old friend I'm so excited oh my God
it's always fun it's always a good old
time podcast Superstar comes to join us
and help us sort out the dumb that has
become our world it's just so good
consummation yeah no we love hanging
with you I remember going to TIG
notaro's birthday party and then just
like making a beeline and we just sat
great chat I loved it we really did we
got into it it was like every time we
see you and like we were writing on this
Kevin Hart uh Keenan Thompson end of the
year thing for peacock and me like in
the room wrote this thing for her to do
it we're like she's gonna come in and
we're gonna write this the way that it
is but like she's gonna come in and just
crush it one take and like everyone's
blowing it almost I had to like walk out
they had to walk out of the studio one
take just like she's gonna be playing a
drunk girl giving a toast at a wedding
I'm like this is Success all the way
through and she laid down face down on
the studio floor at the end and when
they all cut everyone clapped I'm like
this is the first time all day that
we've done that that's so nice that's so
funny had you worked with Kevin before
no that was my first time meeting him so
like I feel like he didn't know who you
were because he knows who very few
people are uh and I was like you could
tell because he's like running through
so much stuff and he's worrying about
his restaurant and this and that and the
other thing and but over 50 other
commercials he's shooting but there was
like a moment where like you could see
he's there like oh [__] this girl is
really funny that's nice that moment it
was like fun for us to watch clicks so
all right we're gonna apply all of that
to the dumb stories that we have we got
one right here and then we'll talk about
all the podcasts and stuff you're doing
Jay let's hop all right I gotta sorry
sent in by Eric James Hitler Hitler
hitner hitner I'm a Hitman or the Hitler
honors program EJ uh here's the here's
the thing you go back in time would you
kill hitting there
I'd kill his friend himner
he's him all right man barges into Fort
Myers home while family eats dinner
claims he is a ghost perfect oh my
nothing could be scarier actually
like first of all I don't know if he is
or not right I've never had a house
right you have to question like you he
might be yeah if you're a ghost though
would you need to barge in or could you
go through a window but we don't know
but also I know this is Florida but
barging makes it feel so Midwestern yeah
it does barge in here it's like
is this like when people say they're
crazy like if they say they're crazy and
then another crazy they're not crazy
I'm a ghost so did they kick him out
well let's get into it Fort Myers
Florida a Fort Myers family had some
unexpected company for dinner on
Thursday night by the way Fort Myers is
where we flew in like when my wife's uh
stepfather was alive and lived on
Sanibel like we Fort Myers is a regular
play this isn't like anything I've never
swamped yeah I've never said this to you
you know Florida Florida I don't at all
I've got Orlando I've been to Orlando
Orlando and Miami I I can I can see it
I've been to Disneyland okay
in Tampa is that a difference okay so
here's how well I know Florida so my
wife's stepfather he and her mother for
years on Sanibel Island which is
beautiful where is that I don't know
what's on the west coast you fly into
Fort Myers so you're on the gulf you're
in the Gulf right so you're flying to
Fort Myers and then you drive over a
Causeway this is like the hurricane like
knock the causeway but like you just you
drive out of the causeway and you're on
this like little island it's so tropical
and actually really cool and really
beautiful and we loved it but then we'd
like drive across the state through like
Alligator Alley which is so funny you
know what that means just small weird
towns that you're like let's not get in
the middle in the middle so you know
where they sell fireworks like up in
Indiana across the border from this is
where I live in Indiana
they ship to the Midwest yeah
do you know the fireworks stand on the
edge of the highway in Indiana
imagine a whole town built off that
that's my kind of place
so it is like fascinating and you so we
drive through and we drove to the other
side which we'd go to Palm Beach and
West Palm Beach Palm Beach is like this
is Atlanta has a place there it's like
super ritzy like I played Boca once but
you're still in and out doing a show
it's kind of near Miami
oh I know right book is like in Palm
Springs but in a tropical area okay but
like if you think about the name of it
Boca Raton mouth of the Rat all right
okay really yeah yep mouth of the Rat
Boca Raton all right so why would you
name something
like rats weren't even good back then
when they were naming [__] like they
were worse they were terrible They
Carried the plate so Buca di Beppo his
mouth
[Laughter]
I've flown into and I'm like it's a very
normal place okay that's what you're
saying it's not crazy but listen we're
not talking about crazy like you
wouldn't expect this to happen it's not
alligator Ally thank you thank you Lord
knows Florida it's not Lake okawala
anyway uh they had unexpected comedy for
dinner this should have been the reboot
of Guess who's coming to dinner I feel
like right so much better right because
I've got to change it a little bit right
like let's make it a ghost that is crazy
to have someone but I love race coming
to dinner now this guy thinks he's a
ghost that's a better movie we've had
stories where people have married ghosts
so guess who's barging marrying a ghost
married again that's a whole thing too
there to go is Keith barged into my
family's dinner love it for saying he
never as soon as I saw him barging in uh
he wanted he had kind of ideas about the
wedding all right
the caslins were sitting down wait who
the mccaslands McCaslin you know that
that's my grandmother's maiden name
okay
c-a-s-l-i-n-m-c-c-a-s-l-i-n
[Laughter]
and it was the basis for A Tribe Called
Quest
now uh mccaslin's were sitting down for
supper when all of a sudden a random man
came barging in the front door uh you
know he oh I don't know I'm giving him
no you should you know no he only had on
a bathing suit no shoes or anything else
said Brian McCaslin Brian McCaslin of
course he didn't have on shoes right if
you're barging into someone's house it's
a miracle he had a baby just because I'm
glad he covered his job Florida guy
barges in the house swimming trunks I'm
picturing full-on board shorts yeah he
hasn't gone up to the I mean seven to
five agencies this is a guy that would
wear board shorts to a funeral
Brian McCaslin who's buried in that
right he died in 96 so uh he's
representing that era right he uh Brian
McCaslin says table with his two teenage
daughters who I'm sure were respecting
the hell out of him
I'm sure they weren't on their phone
blaming him dad
I am don't talk to them
oh my god dad you're so annoying I'm
talking to the ghosts
he so thinks that the ghost is gonna
talk to do something I just got insight
into your dinner time
dude every God why every teenage
daughter what are you doing what am I
doing
[Laughter]
the ghosts
you just don't get it Dad the ghost is
fighting him with probably like a
samurai sword and she's like in his ear
like I'm going to Stacy's for dinner for
sure I'm sleeping the dad is like I'm
gonna throw him out of there and the
daughters are like it's them
uh all right now here's where Brian
starts to give a quote to the news and
gets a little over his ski and tries to
sound more educated than he you know
when people try to summarize well yeah
and they'll start interviewed for the
news
most people words here it's like the kid
apparently yeah I love that kid well
most people don't have sound bites like
locked and loaded and they don't
understand so he started the sound bite
and he was like oh I better sound smart
all right in the middle okay yeah okay
as I walked out of the area where we
were eating dinner at a lot of this
movie okay dining room nice way of not
saying TV room
there was an individual in the living
room or front door area the area is a
big word individual I feel like is
really that's really trying to be like
like a person of interesting
proceeding to advance into my house
proceeding to advance into my house I
love CSI this guy's
is he like putting on rubber gloves as
he's saying and then this is where he
loses steam he was in he was in the
house
by the way all he needed to do was say
the second part he was in he was in the
house that's scary that's enough uh
surprised at what he was seeing McCaslin
said the encounter became even stranger
once the man opened his mouth he started
to tell me that he was a ghost and that
I shouldn't be able to see him
well that's on you okay he was shocked
that I could see him yeah yeah he
thought he was walking around that
nobody could see him but every once in a
while okay when people see ghosts this
is something we know about ghosts right
you can see that a little bit every once
in a while you have a sighting and
that's what makes it exciting like you
saw this answers my other question too
because I didn't know if he like broken
and on the spot was like uh I'm a ghost
or but he I think drugs probably yeah he
thought he was a ghost before he even
he's like no I'll go in here nobody can
see me yeah it's we've this is one of
the oldest things there's like levels of
being drunk and one of them is invisible
where you think what you're doing no one
else can see like when you're that drunk
girl like put that down like nobody's
watching me yeah yeah
look don't look over there it's like
it's like the old I was that Amazon
Women on the moon or Kentucky Fried
Movie the thing of Ed Begley Jr played
the son of the Invisible Man and he took
off all the vantages and he was there
and everyone in the town was like had to
basically so he's a naked guy and he's
like moving stuff
and everyone's just sitting there like
yeah so he thought he was a ghost before
he walked in yeah he thought so but he
obviously doesn't understand that ghosts
aren't invisible this guy's having
trouble now so Brian barely uh able to
believe what he was seeing tried to get
the man back out the front door he came
through there's another quote I could
tell his behavior was not normal said
McCaslin who knows what this person
might do if they have a chance to think
what does that means to not think they
could do anything clearly they haven't
thought together say it again this is a
great this might need to be on a t-shirt
uh no no no it's what this person might
do if they have a chance to think so
many wrong tents so many yeah
everything's wrong and also I don't need
that guy to think at all I think him not
thinking is the part I'm saying if he
thinks about him he'll be like hey what
am I doing in this room and I should
probably put a shirt and some shoes on
and hey I'm not a ghost
that's right after causing the scene
inside this guy who claims his name is
Kevin claims there's no way to find out
right Dan there's no way not an exciting
fake name it's gonna make it up right
Barnaby Kevin
uh came uh running outside to where a
crew was cutting down a tree this is the
crazy what wait hold on so he came
running outside to where a crew was
cutting down a tree I don't want him
near there right dinner time Tree
Cutting Crew yeah that's a late uh okay
he hopped up in one of their trucks and
locked himself inside okay he said he
doesn't have a home and he's going to
make their truck his home okay well is
that a ghost problem or is that Kevin
right I mean we don't have to announce
it you're a ghost you could say also if
you're Brian
and Kevin runs out of your house and
into somebody else's truck you're done
you're done lock the door yeah yeah I'll
go back inside I won't know what's
happening yeah yeah this is your
Poltergeist yeah I'm done and the
daughters are like seriously what are
you doing where's Kevin dad I miss Kevin
so now you kick him out he's homeless
dad doesn't have a home
the best is like just silences they're
eating and like Forks anything and then
just one of the daughters like I Miss
Kelly
they probably miss Mom yeah where's
Mommy
I think it's all wild McCausland said my
teenage girls oh this is my joke of
course is my teenage girls almost even
looked up from their phones that's how
Wild it was yeah okay
oh I was like Brian that's pretty good
that was funny
but the tree trimmers were able to get
the man out of the truck where he ran
away still wearing nothing but his
bathing suit
yeah you're not gonna go into a tree
trimmer truck and suddenly like have
like an outfit change like it's not
gonna be wait no rest
no oh well you'll get to it uh called
the Lee County Sheriff's Office filed a
report he now wants deputies to find the
man but not press charges so this guy
doesn't want to press charge Brian Brian
McCaffrey your relatives did stop they
don't want to press charges so here's
how much I was embroiled in Florida my
wife's stepfather was the fire
commissioner on Sanibel Island and I met
the Lee County Commissioner this guy I
don't know if it's this guy but I met
you at the time I met the guy he was
over at their house for Christmas the
Lee County Commissioner so like I'm like
two degrees away
let's find Kevin let's find Kevin
hopefully we can find this individual
and get them the help they need which I
think is nice we need to talk we need to
talk about Kevin yeah we do we need to
talk about it okay so what about that's
very kind that's the kindest like
reaction to a ghost man who barged into
your house and then we need to find him
we need to find this guy we need to get
him some help and then the article said
if you have information that might help
investigators you can submit an
anonymous online tip through SW
Crime Stoppers or call
1-800-980-tips I'm really Amazed by that
ending right like they that he didn't
have vitriol for this guy yeah I didn't
really do anything but it would be
really scary
you're sitting eating dinner on barges
yeah barging into your house like he
didn't just like tiptoe in he barred he
cramered his way into that house damn I
love it well that's it I love that story
we well townies get a follow-up townies
if you're in this if you know what's
happening send a tip in to 1-800 all
right let's join number one down in the
books Lauren Lapkus is with us we're
going to find out uh they're gonna find
out how you can follow her on podcast on
the podcast that she's doing two
fantastic ones we'll do it and we'll let
you know what we're doing it's all on
the other side of the breaking stone
people town we'll be right back hey guys
welcome back to the show before we get
to the podcast you can support Lauren in
and and listen to her because she's
wonderful uh we'll tell you a couple
things that we have going on uh we're
doing uh our Target show in September so
we have three things coming up in
September we're going to be in Ann Arbor
at the Ann Arbor comedy Showcase with
our buddy Jeff Tice I love this club
it's September 8th and 9th so I will
have dropped my daughter off at school
and then two weeks later I just show up
again like a helicoptering around the
cow and when's parents weekend parents
weekend is November 4th so I'll be there
he's gone I'll be right back I'll be
back again so this club is really
special we try we did everything we
could and had a fundraiser to try and
save this club during the pandemic and
they just got through and they are
surviving and doing well we feel so
connected to this place it's where we
performed when we were in college there
so I love this place love Roger Feeney
the guy who does it and Dan should be
there performing this uh fall as well so
we'll be there the 8th and 9th uh and
then we're doing our Target show which
is so fun and we've mentioned it many
times in the show comedians do their
sets Jay and I are off to the side
writing little joke pitches and then we
pitch them our jokes right afterwards
that's fun super fun super collaborative
it's basically what we all do on this
podcast the collaboration we do it's we
bring that to the stage so we're doing
on the 13th at uh The Comedy Store in
the belly room uh and the guests will
include uh many guests who have been on
the show Ian Carmel Jamie Lee uh militia
Melissa via Senor great great people
will be
and then uh on the 18th at Largo and
that one's going to be a special one uh
Kumail is going to be on that show
Patton's going to be on that show
looking like maybe Adam Sandler on that
show it's going to be really fun again
and special and Fortune feedster is
going to be on that shows good people
all the way around so again those will
put all those up on supersclass.com but
Largo on the 18th that and that uh
Lauren let's talk about uh what you have
the podcast I have a podcast called
Freedom with Scott ockerman and Paul F
Tompkins where we just tell stories from
our lives and we make fun of each other
and we do bits and it's just it builds
upon itself for years and um
it's insane and then we we play a game
at the end submitted by a listener and
so it's either an improv game or some
sort of like word game or something
where we [__] with each other and it's
always fun
um and then I have a show called
newcomers with Nicole buyer where we
watch things we've never seen that like
everyone in the world has seen so we did
Star Wars we did a Lord of the Rings
Fast and the Furious Tyler Perry movies
um we're doing Batman now all of them in
the series yeah
[Applause]
only there are we're doing 14 episodes
of Batman like how do they get to do
that do that like just be like let's do
another Batman like it's the same
freaking story I'll find out because
yeah I'm I'm on like uh the third movie
now or something is there ever a moment
where you're watching you're like what
am I doing what am I I wonder that all
the time with this podcast because I'm
like okay now I have to watch Clone Wars
or something I'm like I don't know like
if any homework is like three hours of
stars but Batman I'm enjoying so far but
that's yeah I love timber yeah but yeah
we'll see once again the Heath Ledger
Joker Joel Schumacher oh my goodness
that is like that is a masterful oh yeah
yeah
man look I like Michael Keaton too I
mean I love Michael Keaton Keaton as
Batman got so much grief Kilmer is back
Keaton got a lot of grief because they
thought he was being fun they thought no
it was before it came out he would like
when he accepted the this is crazy but
the MTV Movie Awards like were huge it
was him and Jack Nicholson at the MTV
yeah and he said a thing when he
accepted that award something like for
everybody who thought I was the wrong
person for this role because there was
huge backlash against him being cast
because it was like Mr Mom and uh yeah
because Beetlejuice hadn't come out yet
oh okay so he wasn't seen that way no
but he was a stand-up like oh I don't
know I've been like the late 70s and he
was so fun I mean a guy who's Mr Mom the
the one where you know I've never seen
that oh my God
is is him and Henry Winkler and Shelley
Long wow what was crazy about the Henry
Winkler role is that at the time when it
came out Happy Days was the biggest
thing ever and he was the fonts he was
just cool as hell and in this movie
night shift he plays a very probably
closer to Henry Winkler is like the
sweetest most put upon a guy ever and uh
Michael Keane is just as out of control
like hilarious he's basically someone
saw Michael Keaton do stand up and
they're like all right let's just put
let's just put that in the thing I bet
he wrote a bunch of his riffs on the
thing too and it's just amazing anyway
oh good super fun anyway but there was a
lot of grief he got a lot of grief well
I think he's a great Batman but I agree
well people can hear you talk about it
yeah I would love to hear my opinions
and Nicole and I often have crazy ones
and we also rate people on a horniness
scale so there's a lot going on with the
newcomers
those are two things you should just
start subscribing to those all right you
guys want to do a story let's do another
one this was sent in by Beck s at Dr BX
underscore I think she's uh yeah she's a
doctor unless that's actually this is so
dumb the musician Aussie man right so I
already know this drinking is gonna be
wild yeah Aussie man whose finger was
severed by a crab on a fishing trip
start over
Aussie man whose finger was severed by a
crab on a fishing trip uses the digit as
bait to catch a fish no let me put that
on how quickly over the fact that your
finger fell off they were just like
that's baked now it's gone but this is
part of you sir yeah this is a fantastic
male to me I can think of nine reasons
why you shouldn't do that yeah I would
and you know that's gonna cast it out
there it's just gonna fall off yeah
looks done also by the way that would
hurt so [__] bad I cut my hand
[Music]
no no
washing a fancy knife and it just like
flipped and I was like blood like I
literally said blood like it was so I
didn't know what to do and my I could
like see things happening and it was so
crazy and it hurts so bad still to this
day if I like hit it again really
because of the nerves yeah it was like
right on the nerve yeah but if you lose
so you know the story when I planned
this on the first anniversary of our
wedding when I I planned the trip of our
first anniversary up to Napa and we
stayed like in Napa which is not nice at
all you know like you don't know these
things when you're trying to plan a trip
or when you're just a young seven I was
27 years old I was so dumb and like you
know I planned a hot air balloon ride
that where you know the story of the guy
who was so there's a guy who the pilot
of the hot air balloon his name was
Maverick I'm like not a good name yeah
bad story you know what a guy who's like
gonna go Rogue right well so then I
don't want to get in the hot air balloon
I looked down it I didn't either but I
looked down in his hand and he's missing
like two and a half fingers and I was
like from pulling that thing I don't
know I'm like he's either he's either
really takes a lot of chances that he
shouldn't or he's really unlucky either
way that's bad for us and then of course
we were supposed to go one mile up one
mile over a one mile down we went one
mile up and then Maverick radios down to
the van which has all of our stuff
underneath and it's like I got a wind
I'm going with it we go 14 miles in
another Direction into another Valley
that's so long so weird wait why does it
work now and he's radioing down to the
Vantage and said and we're in the I mean
we're all in the basket it's like me and
my wife and a handful of other people
yeah we're like What are we how are we
gonna land this thing or where are we
going because there's a designated spot
to land it and he's he's like knock on
doors and see if we can land on people's
houses he's radioed down to the van and
then he's like I see an area between a
house on a farm between a house and the
hillside I'm going to try and put it
down and as we're coming down he's like
okay when the basket hits everyone jump
I'm like what elevator trick right yeah
like crazy so but when you see some my
point being when you see someone who is
like missing fingers you got to ask
yourself was that an accident what did
he do I did one really bad I just not
thinking
I had I was I had a I was peeling a lot
of like carrots and I just was like oh
let me get that carrot and I just ran my
own
blade and I looked I looked at myself
and I'm like what did I just do like in
my mind I was on the back side of it or
you could even get feel the hurt you
were in the show oh I watched it yeah I
watched it just split yeah and then uh
one time I had a buddy who we were up at
the cabin and he was trying you already
know where this is gonna go he was
trying to separate Frozen patties with a
knife nope nope nope I know nope and I I
you do that with a screwdriver I was
like in slow motion I was like I tried
to tell him to stop
people just running Under the Sea yeah
yeah just letting it under the water
yeah what you always do is you have both
your hands right there and you're trying
with a knife to try and like so right
down the center of his hands so we're
just going to throw this on the hook and
just okay so his finger came off and
within moments here and he just came off
from a crab which is probably him
[__] with a car crab bit it off a
keen fisherman recounted a tail not for
the squeamish after he revealed he used
his own severed finger as bait after a
crab snipped it off but I'm sorry you
still have time to save it like right
you could keep it back so this is how
dumb people Flex I can't believe drunk
dumb people The Man known only is Chris
from Townsville yeah don't give him a
laugh no that's how he likes to be yeah
it's the John male Cincinnati hi I'm
Chris from Thomasville I like video
games and I don't like girls with long
hair he's on next okay
give me a high five give me a high four
and a half next
and all the guys are the worst they're
all the worst the worst next MTV trash
and it's all double entenders and bad
puns yeah it was the beginning of uh
Tinder yeah yeah yeah
in real life and then they all had to
hang out on the bus and how much you
would see these men like try to cover up
their insecurities by being like I'm
gonna I'm gonna make her next to me it's
like you're just hurting you're just
hurting I'm gonna make her next I'm
gonna make her next to me yeah how about
room Raiders though remember that one
silence
Silent Library is still one of the
funniest yeah they had you to be silent
you would go to the library
song group of friends sitting at a table
and they would have somebody do like you
would have to like hit a mousetrap or
something but you couldn't make any
noise and if you would get money if you
stayed below a certain like noise yes
Silent Library is wildly hilarious no
when we were in college we had a theory
our friend had a friend Mark had a
theory that like when we're in the law
library you can make a really loud noise
as long as it's super short and nobody
will do anything
sit down next to me and be like
no one would do anything it's a fun game
but if you were like hey
and then someone else would have to say
it louder than the person before them
and so you get to a point where people
be like
God it was so funny this is funny it is
wildly fun then it becomes how quickly
you say yeah yeah and how much you can
make it sound like something else that's
it the Man known only is Chris from
Townsville and Far North Queensland
called into triple M's the rush hour
with a b and Elliott triple M's the rush
hour with a b and Elliot which that's
that's
a radio show yeah it was a long weekend
fishing trip and we've been out for
beers for a while and we decided to drop
the crab thoughts out he told the
captivated hosts the angler explained
that he and his mates returned to camp
and had a few more beers before checking
the pots after a few hours important
detail I pulled up one and grabbed one
of the crabs and he bit me on my left
pointing finger he's playing your index
finger yes
he uses this one yeah my pointing
fingers listen you [__]
Chris was like I'm still drunk how weird
is this this is uh my car's not over
there
you don't talk to me that way you don't
do it I pick which finger I point with
not you you something Mr what it's so it
doesn't do anything no yeah that would
be wild to be sure I was over here okay
uh well you go that way he claimed he
didn't feel anything amiss but when he
looked down about half his finger was on
the floor of the boat half the boys
decided anything a mess the boys decided
we might call it quits and head you home
and I said no we've traveled all this
way so we ended up staying and fishing
the next day the next day next day days
are passing I think that might be bad
you're like dude you're you're really
bumming a lot of us out you're infected
yeah in pain yes you're pretending it's
fine yes remarkably unconcerned about
reattaching his finger the lorican I
don't know what that that's awesome
where he's from yeah uh but it's not
even capitalized explained he was trying
to be funny when he instead attached it
to his line and threw it overboard it's
hilarious that is kind of fun trying to
be funny there's like so and then the
next line should be like he's not a
comedian yeah he was trying to be funny
he ended up catching a how many pound
golden trivali heavily I have no idea I
don't know they look like this he caught
like a big fish they look like that oh
Jesus oh Jesus well I've zoomed in but
finding there's no perspective it's a
stunning fish
protected
with his finger how many pounds of that
fish a golden trevally traveling I don't
know people actually okay what do you
think I'm gonna say I don't know how
much a fish weighs I don't know what's
normal I mean I'm gonna go with 11 11
pounds three pounds three two pounds two
pounds
I ended up catching a 25 pound goal oh
my God that is so big you guys again
it's neon and it's so pretty wow and it
had a finger inside it
it was the biggest fish we caught that
weekend so I had bragging rights well
okay you lost bragging rights when you
threw your finger on those that's right
you're stupid I think they should then
send the fish away stuff it and he
should replace his finger with a fin
yeah just like have one little thing you
have bad friends they should have been
like we're done we let him hang out yeah
we're done crazy I had a friend who lost
half a finger finger in anything trips
over trips over there's no pardon me
it's like we came a long way I'd like to
stay here yeah right our drunkest guy
takes you to urgent care and you spend
the night and you deal with the closest
guy yeah let that guy sober him up yeah
I know and then you just go that's the
night you bring 10 beers and get them to
attach the fingers and that's a story
too that's a great story
then he went back out the next day and
he got his or like or have him making
like a trick finger so like at parties
you're gonna be like Boop and take it
off and put it on time bring it back on
again like yeah or donate it to a bar
there's a drink in Yukon at this bar
it's called the severed toe shot or
whatever and then you have a toe and
they put it in there you drink it and
you kiss the toe when it hits your lips
and put it back and it's real yeah some
people have accidentally swallowed it
they were missing one they were missing
one and so people donated other ones
Jason didn't handle this story very well
donated none of us did so I'm saying
like you could donate it to your local
bar and be like yes the finger it's
better than it honestly it's better than
a toe there's something so gross about
it thank you just the idea of toes the
idea of toes especially separated from
the rest
severed toes yes uh all right that's
store number two
uh so I know we kind of so this I don't
I don't know why this show is like very
animal oriented I believe my third story
is about a uh a guy this again is in
Florida and it just is like how stupid
can you be related to animals outside
your door pretty stupid very stupid it's
dumb people Town Lauren Lapkus is with
us we'll find out what Dan's got going
on right after this break
[Music]
we want to tell you about our sponsor
prize picks prize picks is the most fun
that we've had winning money up to 25
times our money this football season all
you have to do is select two or more
players pick more or less the projected
stats and place your entry it's really
fun to test our skills on prize picks
this football season it's the most
exciting way to play daily fantasy
sports if you have skills you can turn
ten dollars into 250 bucks with just a
few Taps Jay I love it because I don't
know about you guys but every year you
know because I'm not as bad as you can
in my fantasy league about four weeks in
I'm like well this season's over right
if you're playing in a formatic cousins
yeah you're in a giant ship Titanic a
fantasy Titanic that's just going down
and you're like second half of them you
don't even want to watch football for
the next day well with prize picks it
makes those weeks after your Titanic
ship goes down fun because you can make
daily picks and it's so great I mean you
can make the pics of like will Aaron
Rodgers throw three touchdowns like like
now all of a sudden a Jets game matters
to you right right that's usually only
reserved for sad people that's right
saquon Barkley could he get 60 yards
rushing it's all first of all they place
the things and you you really have to
think about it but it is really fun
because now you're watching the game
you're so invested in these games that
normally don't matter to you and it
makes the NFL Super Fun in those later
weeks when your other long fantasy team
is dying so here's what we're gonna do
because you're listening you're a DPT
fan you're a townie here's what you do
you go to prize picks.com DPT use the
code DPT for a first deposit match up to
a hundred dollars how about it prize
picks.com TPT use the code DPT for a
first deposit match up to 100 prize
picks daily fantasy sports made easy
[Music]
town
hey guys welcome back to the show before
I jump in and take us home in The Last
Story Daniel let people know where they
can be live and you got a lot of good
stuff yeah between like September 21st
and November 11th I'm doing somewhere
between like 20 and 25 shows townies the
most fun thing if you come out to a show
I'm going to open them by saying anytime
he's here have a headline they want to
read and we will goof around a little
bit before I bring out the host and kick
the show off in Earnest I love it um but
I just locked in uh remember our buddy
uh Hayes permer yes he has he has a
feeder a small little theater in Raleigh
North Carolina I'm playing there for the
first time awesome I believe that's
Saturday October 14th it's one of their
first shows they're ever going to do so
I have never headlined Raleigh and I
can't wait to create 10 shows there but
go to danielvankirk.com I'm going to be
all over the Midwest and the South all
leading up to 11 11. my special taping
and album recording at the Lincoln Lodge
wow Chicago Illinois
go to go to Daniel Van Kirk beautiful
place.com uh links should be up there if
they're not if they're not they will be
soon it's hanging from the rafters at
that show yeah it's going to be great
yeah two that night or one uh I'm doing
two okay so let's fill those shows I
mean this is I would love it they
actually sent us an email last week
saying it looks like it's going to sell
out so based on where we're at right now
so if you want to come out to those
shows get your tickets now yeah and
there will be some sort of uh unofficial
After parties 11 11 is this Saturday all
right so make a weekend of it if you're
nearby you're in Wisconsin or you're in
New York come on down come on guess
where I'm at the night before yeah
Rochelle Illinois oh yeah I'm doing my
hometown are you doing a show yeah I'm
doing a show on Friday I love it yeah at
uh it's called Fat Cats it's my buddy's
bar he's got like a banquet but they
only it only is it only seats like a
hundred people and the last time I did
Rochelle I think we sold like 347.
um but I said hey I want to do it at my
buddy's place give him the business so
we might do two shows but you should if
anybody wants to make a joke
she thinks you're down Fat Cats you
clean it up
big kids your aunt has no idea look
you're gonna have fun you're gonna learn
how to dance
all right so this next story is sent in
by our good friend Jake Rooney at Jake
Rooney this is a story of just what in
the f are you doing and why are you
doing this again
when you put yourself in the position of
people there's no way you would make it
I love this show because there is a
moment in every single it's like when
you're watching football if you're
watching like the watching Patrick
Mahomes you're watching the Kansas City
Chiefs and you're like he's gotta make a
play right here if they're gonna win
this game
now this story came by way of the New
York Post so trigger warning okay there
will be a lot there'll be so many dumb
puns you're going to want to punch
someone in the face so just hold
whatever you do there's like a moment
where I'm reading the New York Post and
I'm like is Rudy Giuliani writing this
does he is he does he just write all the
Articles do you think people who are
like good at puns get excited to like
apply there yeah I could really write
this look at all the puns that all right
so and the other thing about this story
is in a regular world like before we
knew Florida was as crazy it was this
would be the craziest story that anybody
has ever told someone but just because
it's Florida you're like yeah yeah it's
like Soho we've normalized this story so
just keep that in mind okay here we go
it was a very unwelcome house
calls a floor right what is it a Florida
man was attacked by an alligator after
opening his front door Saturday night
according to the report now if you just
open the door and an alligator and you
didn't see the alligator fine I feel bad
for this guy yeah or it's like there's
some motion on the ring go get it yeah
wait what's the old SNL sketch though
Chase Daytona Beach resident Scott
Hollingsworth this guy yeah last name
makes him seem like British yeah
aristocracy like part of the ruling
class yeah sometimes based on a person's
name you can tell they weren't born in
Florida yeah from the house of
Hollingsworth like Hollingsworth not by
hauling's head is like an air we're
taking the kids up to Hollingshead this
weekend all right those guys were told
w-e-s-h that he heard a noise outside
his home at what time hmm 3 A.M 3 A.M
okay what do you think Matchbox Twenty
something uh he must have been lonely
sure he was
[Laughter]
I'm gonna go 8 P.M 8 P.M
11 30 p.m okay get your answers in
townies because this was around I love
they say it's a round and then they give
you exactly 9 42 p.m just around it was
actually
what if it was nice we don't want to
make anyone what if it was 9 45 and
they're like it was around 9 42. we just
like to keep it interesting everybody
says 9 45 9 30 it's like it was around 9
42. it had recently been right no one
can say that it's 9 45 it's not around 9
42 am I wrong it's like when you realize
you've written just too many times in
like a message
it's too chill yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm just wondering if you're wondering
yeah I'm just wondering if it's just not
too big of a deal that just maybe we
should just stop
um wait is it does it say there was a
knock or any noise he heard a noise
outside his home around 9 42 and when he
stepped outside quote something grabbed
me on the legs started shaking violently
so hello yeah yeah what if you're up in
Northern California or in Tahoe and you
hear a noise that could be a bear I mean
if I hear a noise in L.A I don't want to
just open it and see if I hear a knock
I'm not just opening it no need to be
careful Cameron see what's going on
let's walk towards the loud noise is
what I say let me open the door and see
what's going on out here so that now
you're like I feel bad for this guy you
open up the door I feel like the part
where he said something grabbed my leg
and was shaking I'm like there's not
that long we're going something's doing
it like it's like it's like
instantaneously like an alligator like
it's huge something's going on but it's
like Dan when he scraped his finger on
the thing he had to like be like what
something must have happened was weird
this is the point where we will all turn
on this guy he added that he didn't turn
on a light I didn't even get a good look
at the assailant good luck but told the
station he initially thought it was a
dog
I'm sorry if you're gonna go outside how
dark is it it's dark dark it's a very
scaly dog yeah let's go to our Florida
correspondent Randy how dark is it in
that area
no lights at all why would you not turn
on a light not once you hear a noise
yeah look at this
[Laughter]
well I did a bit in my first album about
what happens to people when you're in
the public bathroom and that's exactly
what I said there's a man in here yeah
grown man go away now man with issues in
here it's me I'm in here now
so he's dead about that he then said I
stepped back and closed the door so he
got his leg out of the jaws of a an
alligator yeah and then did he go back
out again and see if it was still there
guys I don't want to talk like I'm a
Florida expert but yeah Amy body of
water or anything you're near you have
to assume we were we were riding our
bikes down through this little pathway
by through a neighborhood and in the
back I looked and I saw two alligators
like outside of a lake area fighting
I don't like that tempting an alligator
with my bicycle riding by I love that
he's like and then I step back inside
and then what'd you do like watch three
more hours of CSI made a Dagwood
sandwich yeah he just chopped his leg
off and fished with it he said he looked
down and he saw he had quote a large
gash on the side of his leg so still
think it's a dog right like you he
didn't see what it was I even think
describing he looked down and it's like
what that's just you don't have to say
that you know you're a huge guys
he looked down and noticed on his leg
there was a line of blood related to a
gash like it just a way to draw it out
overwritten yes it scared the [__] out
of the alligator oh yeah I am concerned
so here's the thing I find the alligator
and get help I mean this this getting
having a huge gash from an alligator is
gonna screw up anybody's okay get to the
Bone imagine what it's this guy the
homie knife has ruined her hand I know
honestly it hurts right now
I did yeah it was crazy that's always a
decision too and you're like am I gonna
go to urgent care I had to oh it was
crazy
and actually just as a sort of story to
warn people my husband like wrapped it
really tightly and then we like got to
the place and they're like it's wrapped
so tightly you could have lost your
fingers yeah because you're you're
stopping and I didn't know that I wasn't
thinking about that I was just more like
we did it like you still hold that
against your husband in other arguments
apply pressure blood pressure but I
think they also like to tell you what
could have happened they're like yeah
you could have lost that finger if you
you're so stupid
alligators yeah exactly if I didn't wrap
it up what would have happened then it
could have bled out and died well the
homeowner who planned to attend this
week's Bike Week what is Bike Week just
just throw that in their
it feels like something for 11 year olds
so yeah yeah you're bringing the kids
down to bike week yeah yeah the tassels
dirt bikes puffy coffee coffee
on Diamondback Harry Larry's instead the
guy required surgery for his injury
until wesa surgery he told everybody
everything's going well but he probably
won't be biking anytime soon which leads
me to leave it is battling on a bike but
also how about I probably won't be
opening the door to noises anymore
probably the right lesson out of that no
he can't go to bike week yeah there goes
bike week
thanks a lot alligator was outside your
door thanks a lot world no I can't go to
bike week yeah you better find out
what's outside your door if you if you
want to go to that place it should be an
ad for ring cameras that's what this
should be yeah or Windows or windows
thank you seriously so we're going to
end it on I mean it's just so stupid
we're gonna in this okay how big so the
authorities came and they found oh they
did they found the alligator lurking
outside of the outside of the area how
big is this alligator who he thought was
a dog okay because this is gonna now
make so we already don't like him he
wanted to go to bike week and that's the
thing about him is that he would make
him down he's mad that he mad that he's
missing Bike Week number one that he
even attends Bike Week makes me not like
him but he's mad he's not going to go to
Bike Week number two he hears a noise
goes outside without turning a light on
without looking at it number three
thinks it's a dog because he hoped
someone else was on the other side of
that yeah yeah yeah he hopes she came
back
Barbara
she's out there making a noise
she wants you to find her my ex-wife is
wrestling wait till I tell her that I
found me
that's so her that was our thing she did
that yeah that's her baby she loves to
Russell she likes to get low all right
so how big
is it measured in feet oh it's measured
in feet okay I'll go first yeah
seven feet seven feet all right that's
huge but I was gonna go bigger but now
I'm doubting myself you can do it
everywhere the tail they add the length
of the tail go with your gut I think
it's the same thing as the weight I gave
to the fish but 11 feet 11 feet what do
you think that I was gonna say 11. uh
how about nine feet nine feet okay one
of you is exactly right now we get to
play the game he said seven seven eleven
nine now you can stay where you're at or
you can jump to a different one it's so
fun okay I'm gonna do nine you could do
nine I'm gonna jump to 11. that's what I
want to do something sticking with seven
okay slit we switched get your answers
in townies okay because the alligator
that was found lurking outside of this
man's door that he thought was a dog
because he didn't turn a light on and it
grabbed his legs can't go to bike week
is
nine feet
so good what a great way to end a
fantastic that is
no that's a big dog
sounds like dogs and I don't think it
would smell like a dog
don't be stupid turn the light on
everybody we love you so much here's
what you're gonna do you're gonna go see
Dan uh at all of his shows it's
definitely on 11-11 yeah bring a
headline CS Ryan Arbor you're gonna see
us when we do the tag it shows you're
gonna subscribe and listen to freedom
and newcomers those are two new podcasts
in your Cube I love you guys thanks sir
thanks for being on the show Anna oh
[__] we gotta get back to work so we'll
see you
people town
[Music]